hey youtubers thank you everyone that
came to my marvel QA the other day just
in case you didn't make the stream I'm
uploading part of this video but there's
also been some like really big rumors
flying around this morning so Batman vs
Superman might be two films I kind of
think it's bull crap there was an image
that was posted this is what it looks
like i'll put it up right here I don't
think this is the real deal I think
somebody just did this in Photoshop the
first trailer is supposed to come with
Jupiter ascending on februari six so
hopefully we'll find out them whether or
not it's real there's also new trailers
for arrow season 3 in the flash that
feature a bunch of new characters so I'm
going to do videos for both of those two
next they'll be two trailer breakdowns
and I'm also working on a Sherlock video
while I'm working on those videos please
enjoy some of this Marvel stream just
bear in mind that it's pretty raw I mean
it's unedited everybody how's it going I
decided to fire a prison architect I
don't have any Marvel games loaded on my
computer right now all my marvel games
are on my mobile phone my iphone uh I
mean spider-man you know I mean yeah
Marvel could probably do something more
interesting with the character but no I
mean I don't care if he's if he's not in
Avengers you know like I'm not gonna
care they already have like way too many
characters that are going to be in that
next movie in the third Avengers movie
uh Hawkeye ant-man jiff no I did not see
that he is like Jeremy Renner um said
that he's putting his suit back on for
another Marvel project most believe that
its agents of shield because that but
there will be an Avenger like a
real-deal Avenger from age of Ultron on
agents of shield and he's just like one
of the most likely candidates the
current plot and agent Carter well we
actually I mean we don't know enough I
think the way they explained it in the
episode is that there's about six pieces
of stark Tech and that that formula was
just one of them so I think that that is
going to be the thing that they chase
around like those different things that
got stolen so Dominic Cooper isn't in
every episode are not in like a big way
it's mostly based on Peggy Carter so
when he said I'm gonna go to Europe and
chase down the ones that are there that
was like his excuse to like get him
off-screen so Peggy Carter mostly going
to be staying in the United States
tracking down the stuff that's you know
been stolen in the United States map
Easter Egg black panther uh yeah there
was a name there was a name or Easter
egg in the first captain america movie
to for Atlantis that doesn't mean
they're going to use them the rights
issues for a name or are a little fuzzy
I think universal might still have the
rights for him otherwise like they
probably would have mentioned him in a
bigger way Agent Coulson is director get
Nick freeze in the movie yeah the movie
is going to explain that yeah don't like
don't get too worried about stuff like
that there's Cinematic Universe in their
television shows they're all connected
but they have like their movie cast and
they have like their TV cast the reason
why you see in DC does this a lot more
the reason why you see like some actors
get recast like in the DC Universe
they'll recast TV actors roles with
movie actors you know when it gets to
like the you know two three four hundred
million dollar level they feel like the
TV actor who ever they cast can't open
like a hundred and fifty million dollar
movie that's mostly like a financial
decision they feel like those movie
people have a broader appeal
internationally so they're talking like
China people like places outside the
United States which I'm sure I'm sure
they're a bunch of you and in the
channel here that are actually have from
outside the United States so it's like
different actors are popular inside the
United States than outside so like Tom
Cruise not really popular in the United
States super popular internationally
which is why he still gets hired to make
movies it gets paid you know the amount
of money he does stark and bancos plans
uh venko was actually one of the coolest
things I got so excited when I saw him I
read he was going to be in the series I
just I didn't know how they were going
to use him so the when they went to see
him to get information about the bomb
the nitramene it was at stark labs so
this is like some time before they have
their falling out and if they get a
season 2 maybe they'll explore that more
but i don't think that Vanko is going to
be as big a part early on i think i
think they'll just go to him every once
in a while dil um yeah this like the
eight episodes they wrote it you know
assuming that they were
gonna get it season two so it's not like
there's going to be a big hanging
hanging plot I mean they'll throw like
the play announce whether or not they're
going to renew it before the before it's
over but they wrote it so that it's like
a fairly satisfying conclusion and
they're building towards like something
big I mean I have no idea what but it'll
presumably explain how the show is
connected to the movies in a bigger way
teaser before Jupiter ascending they're
like yeah there are a lot of like likely
candidates for teaser dates Super Bowl
is one of them the problem with the
Super Bowl is is that it's like four
million dollars or like two million
dollars for like a 30-second spot so if
they do err trailer during the Super
Bowl it'll be like a 30 second version
of the trailer and then they'll be like
go online to see the full trailer you
know which is kind of douchey kind of a
douchey thing to do Warner Brothers will
do like a really big Marvel style
comic-con panel they're planning one
because they'll actually have footage
for Batman vs Superman like this past
year at comic-con they had like they had
just started filming so they really
didn't have much yes yeah yeah I'll be
doing weekly agent Carter videos I'm
more worried about daredevil daredevil
actually at so April 10th they actually
moved it up originally it was listed for
like may the first which is the day that
Ultron age of Ultron comes out so they
moved it up so like what they're doing
is like to get you thinking about Marvel
things they'll have agents of shield and
then they'll have daredevil so it'll be
like then like shooting like Marvel
shotgun at your face just so you know
they'll be running all kinds of like
crazy Ultron ads it's gonna be fun like
April May June will be like crazy moral
time um yeah actually for some reason
comiXology does not have like a social
page where it's like you can go and like
visit a profile where you can see like
the stuff that i buy most of the comics
that i'm buying right now are Marvel and
image comics it's like like my favorite
new comic right now like my brand new
one is manifest destiny the a man comic
i bought the a man comic that they just
they restarted it it's like am a number
one with Scott Lang and he's working
with it's like kind of tying in with
with Stark Industries and Tony Stark
it's look like it's going to be fun a
man is like a really weird character I
think they're just trying to create more
awareness for like the Scott Lang
character so that people are you know
kind of understand where he's coming
from he's very different from like the
other Marvel heroes just because the
arrow and flash trailer videos are
pretty easy for me to get out i'm going
to post those videos next so be sure to
subscribe to get everything in the
meantime you can click here to watch the
ant-man trailer again I know it sounds
weird it's going to be an awesome movie
it'll be a lot of fun and click here for
my agent Carter review thank you so much
for watching so let's all high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you